okay so a little bit of background i
went to this town called shortage um by
my damn self which wasn't the best idea
in hindsight but
my idea was i wanted to go talk to
people about their opinions on father's
rights
after they got out of the bar
question of the day why do women crown
themselves a queen i did get a lot of
these questions from the it's
complicated channel literally this man
has the best questions and the best
content so if you want to give him a
follow please do so
or wait i'm on youtube a subscribe
please do so
um because i did i want to give credit
where credit is due because we are
queens
i don't have an answer we know our value
and our worth beyonce if you look at a
queen a queen has a very high status and
stature you know she carries herself in
a certain way people treat her a certain
way and so that's why we refer to
ourselves as queens because we deserve
to be treated a certain type of way and
we need to look at ourselves a certain
type of way as well i don't know maybe
they feel superior
they feel they're very cool or something
i don't know yeah i'm afraid i don't
know because we are
we are we like we have to make our space
yeah why what do women do that is
special we create life
we create lives well we need two to
great life we just we're just
we're the carriers of life yeah aren't
women the harbors of life since we can't
conceive without a man yes yes yes
all right would you wouldn't you say we
foster life and not create it because we
need the sperm
yes
yes yes yes
yes
are we the harbors of life because we
can't see without matter because if they
wipe women out there'll be no more life
but if we white men out we'll still be
able to create life
are they not am i not wrong genetically
creating sperm what
they're not they're not creating sperm
they're just taking a smaller like guy's
sperm and like putting it so yeah we
need but we need i guess but for now do
you feel like if if um science continues
and they have artificial booms would
that take away how special women are no
but you said they're special because we
we give birth right well i think we're
special because because what's wrong
with you
because we know our value we know our
worth and that's why i was men are
special too thank you very much i was
waiting yeah the men were all special in
our own way not just they're not that
great
whatever but if everyone's special that
isn't no one's special i guess so
i guess so
yeah
i'm just trying not to get cancelled
that's all
wait where is this how many followers do
you have on youtube 150
000. can we 000.
so the first couple of people were
actually really fun to talk to and i
thought that they could really see where
i was coming from with where men deserve
rights to right the focus of this
conversation wasn't on abortion even
though i am pro-life it really was meant
to show that there are double standards
in society that do not benefit men and
you know they have it harder than a lot
of times we give them credit for why is
it when a man abandons his child he's
called a deadbeat dad right
but if a woman abandons her child we
call it the right to choose do we call
him do we do we use that term do we use
that yeah the right to choose if a man
decides he doesn't want to be a father
right we call him a deadbeat dad but
maybe because it's more frequent in men
than it is in women it's more frequent
than men
no it's not no i mean in some in the us
and some states one out of four women
have had an abortion but when you think
about it like when when a man doesn't
want to be a [ __ ]
when a woman doesn't want to be a mother
right she can get an abortion but when a
man doesn't want to be a father he's in
he has skills to pay child support don't
women pay child support too not really
not really 90 of the cases women win is
it so in for example when a woman's like
before child is one yeah they get a lot
of milk
so and they breastfeed and all that
stuff so
is it because women have a natural
more of a maternal instinct i'm not
trying to sound stupid but then why
would they get an abortion if they have
a maternal instinct
because um because people aren't having
protected sex yeah life is yeah
just anyone don't like surely like and
with no resources
like you know what i mean like this is a
baby it's something that you should
share i don't think that i think it's
more resources
right the point is like if a woman wants
to be a she doesn't want to be a mother
she can have an abortion but if a man
doesn't want to be a father just walk
away from me no but but but he's
entitled to child support for 18 years
so he can walk away but he's still he
could go to jail for not paying child
support crazy actually the way that you
think about that because we have the
right to choose but men don't
and the funny thing is a lot of
feminists do agree that it is not fair
and when i talk to a lot of women they
agree more than they disagree that it's
not fair that men are
on the hook for a child but a woman
isn't yeah that choice is based on the
woman's choice yeah and how does it
become fair it's not fair because life
isn't fair yeah unfortunately it's a
double standard i don't think it's a
double standard i think it's just life
isn't equal men don't carry children so
they don't they don't get to choose i
get to choose what i want to do with my
body their choice is protecting
themselves as much as they can do you
think it's my wallet my choice if it's
our body our choice
that's kind of crazy my wallet my choice
what does that mean and then like do i
get to choose
so it's my it's my body my choice right
so shouldn't it be his wallet his choice
i guess so
i guess
if we're about equality right
pay child support anyway i said a lot of
men don't pay child support they run
yeah like way in this country anyway but
when they do it's not like a high amount
it's like 30 pounds a month
so does it really benefit the woman are
they really paying their way
not really maybe richard men are paying
child support like celebrities but
they're standard guy
he's not paying that much but when you
when you think about it right so when
women are incentivized to get babies off
of rich guys so a guy can do everything
right wear a condom have protected sex
outside of abstinence right and she
could still steal the condom as we saw
in the drake hot sauce incident and so
so women are incentivized to get a baby
off of a rich guy because she's on the
hook for child support for 18 years
what it's a long time 18 years yeah and
he any 18 years and he could do
everything right right where we on the
other hand we have birth control we have
abortion we have we have abstinence we
have adoption we have all of these these
accidents yeah and see this is a lot of
the double standards that you see as you
can see in her language she's holding
men accountable but the women aren't and
that's my question to feminists why is
nothing ever our fault if you get
pregnant it's your own fault but for
some reason in our society we always
have to put the blame on the men even
when sometimes it's the woman
they have abstinence yeah yeah so do we
yeah so do they so they could just not
have sex yeah right but so so could we
right that's true and so what i'm
talking about is to make it equal to
make it equal it will never be equal
it will only be equal if men can give
birth too that's true a woman can choose
whether or not she wants to have a child
or not
do you know what i mean a man could do
what he does and a woman decides a man
can choose yeah but you can't unless you
say but i mean like he's not going to
carry the baby do you know what i mean
like it's not you know if the woman says
do you know what i'm keeping it is what
always saying she's not keeping it what
is what are you gonna do yeah do you
know what i mean
what's harder giving birth or raising a
child raising a child yeah raising
because giving birth isn't temporary
it's like what 12 hours 24 hours yeah
but a child is for life
so then by that logic wouldn't it be
harder on the guy
no he could just forget about it because
he's on the hook for 18 years she just
has to give birth no no and the woman
will also be on the hook for my mother
yeah
yeah as well yeah she's raising the
child i think yeah
not if she doesn't want to be a mother
right
it's only if she wants to be a mother
if she doesn't want to be the mother she
wouldn't i guess have the child but if
she didn't want it can't you can't you
like legally like renounce your status
as a child's father like is it like if
you say okay maybe i want to put the
child up for adoption can you not just
like have no attachment to the child is
that not possible if the woman wants to
yeah but that's in the women's hands
there's actually cases in the u.s where
the dad wanted to be involved and the
mother still gave the kid up for
adoption and he was trying to get his
kids
very little in the court system let's
say if the woman wants to give the child
away but the man wanted to keep the
child there would be no way for the man
to do that
they would
i might is that they were just fine i
guess
automatically it's the woman's choice
right so he has to go to court it took
this man two years to get his kid he
missed out on two years then that
shouldn't be the case i think whoever is
a parent should be able to choose to
raise a child
it shouldn't just be on the woman that
okay i get to choose to put my child up
for adoption there's a man involved too
so these guys are really cool i felt
like at first they could not see at all
where i was coming from
um but then it's kind of like when you
ask certain questions it's interesting
to see people kind of stop and think
twice about it so that's what i liked
about these guys is they were very open
to like learning new ideas so would you
guys support a financial abortion so
like women can have an abortion and men
can have a financial abortion if they
don't want to be a dad
so like so like it's an accidental
pregnancy and then he says i want you to
get an abortion she says no and he says
i'm going to sign off my rights would
you support that i would support it i
would say yeah they do that anyway
like yeah but yeah like maybe in this
country they do that anyway so there are
many men
there are many men where they just don't
want to be fathers and they just leave
yeah and that's it
no contact they don't help them
support anything there was nothing that
they had to legally sign they just
didn't if we were ever to accidentally
get pregnant
um
and let's say the father didn't want to
keep
if he didn't yeah i would be like this
is my choice if you want to raise a
child with me then that's fine if you
don't then that's also okay
i think that's how it should be you know
like you present it like i'm gonna keep
the baby you hope in it like you got a
kind of
like pressure minute like some men need
to be kind of precious
because
no i'm not pushing you to raise your
child
but i mean like but see notice this
again it's always on the man the men
have to be more careful but what about
the women what about the women
it's never on us i'm so tired guys
if you're a dude hold these women
accountable it doesn't make you look
good
to always put the onus on men like women
need to be careful too
if you don't want to then that's on you
buddy yeah don't don't be quick
like children don't have their dads in
their life just in general wouldn't it
like
that's your choice fathers are in their
children's life but they're not present
so they're there but they're not
actually present so there's like a
difference that's your choice because
the moment i found out i was pregnant i
chose to step up so why can't you do the
same why should i have to pressure you
into stepping up don't you guys think
it's on the woman though for picking
someone that isn't a father because a
lot of times what i see is girls
sleeping with guys that clearly aren't
husbands and then they get pregnant and
then they get what do you mean by that
so so a girl will sleep with a guy that
clearly doesn't want to commit to her
anytime soon right he's made it he's
made it clear this is this is i am the
street right i am i'm straight
and then the girl says okay she gets
pregnant by him right and then she's mad
that he's not a dad or a husband but she
but she picked him right it's kind of on
her i'm not going to lie
you choose who you want to be no one
puts a gun to you and say you better be
with me do you know what i mean like you
know what i mean you've got to be
accountable people don't like because
you have to be a councilwoman yeah
because it takes two to have a you know
a child
it takes two to have a child so yes i
may have you know that day decided to
have sex with you but you also decided
to have sex with me and you need to know
that when you have sex they'll go there
can be
there's going to be results sometimes it
can lead to children and you need to
accept
whatever outcome but the problem is a
guy could do everything right and she
could still steal your condom shouldn't
there be a law to protect guys and stuff
like that i agree there should be yeah
yeah some sort of law if you can prove
that this person took my sperm without
my right
then
why not yeah
all right do you think
we should support a woman who aborts her
child because it's what's best for her
yes a woman should have the right to
make her own decision yes
freaking yes
then should we support a man who
abandons his kid because that's what's
best for him
yes
yes yes okay okay cool yes oh you're
consistent no okay no no commander
doesn't want his child
a man that doesn't want his child do you
have the same energy like find a woman
who doesn't want her child yeah
because a woman is a lot like i think
both okay yeah shout out is this is all
getting too political and i can't be
saying these things on camera
this is my manager like
i know i can't get cancelled for none of
this please this can't go on youtube i'm
sorry
i can't i can't do this
you didn't tell me what it was about i
can't i'm sorry no i don't sign the
disclosure so you can't put this on
youtube so if this goes on youtube yeah
no you can't put this
you don't have anything you can't you
don't legally if you do a public
interview you can't i'm gonna be honest
this guy i think was too drunk to be
doing this interview i don't even know
if he knew what i was asking he may
regret doing this interview now but you
know here we are is it is it harder to
give birth or raise a child considering
i've done both i would say that
raising a child yeah raising yeah okay
why is it if a woman can't pay for her
baby she gets government assistance
right but if a man can't pay for his
baby he goes to jail i feel like that's
because we're expected to look after the
baby so there's support and stuff
well
minor very very little support for us to
do this but a man is not expected to
take care of the baby so there's not
really that much support for them i
don't think it's expected when he has to
pay if he doesn't it's not really
typical that a woman has to pay child
support because i feel like
that's the only type of support that a
man
we can force a man to give because they
will not be there emotionally they will
not give the
like they will not raise the child the
way a woman will
but
yeah take the money from them yeah yeah
you think they should take the money yes
yes
is it solely the man responsible for
getting the woman pregnant or does it
take two people i think it's
the guy it's the guy yes because i feel
that
when i rub against a woman i don't get
pregnant so
when you rub against a woman yeah like
if i sleep with a woman i won't get
pregnant but for sleeping for a man i
will get pregnant and i feel that it is
your responsibility to make sure that
that doesn't happen because i feel like
it's
society just naturally feels like it's
our responsibility to make sure when
iuds bring the condoms and things like
that so yeah so wouldn't it be more the
woman's responsibility that she doesn't
get pregnant since we have the option to
get an iud and birth control and an
abortion
no because i kind of look at it like
edward scissorhand he has these scissor
hands and it's not the world's
responsibility to make sure that he
doesn't cut them it's his responsibility
to sort of make sure that you know we
don't think it's our responsibility we
choose who we have sex with right of
course but
what didn't you say it's our
responsibility
like how is it more on the guy when it
takes two to tango
they're the ones that create that thing
like without them
i can't make a baby yeah but without
like it takes two without um
no
no i'm still i'm still okay okay do you
think it's women's duty to have kids or
it's their choice choice choice
100
why do women claim to be the creators of
life when the pregnancy is unwanted but
when the child is wanted it becomes a
man's fault for not wearing a condom oh
that's a hard one
i feel
that oh i don't know i don't know what
to say yeah i actually think yeah that's
it
okay
is it rude to ask a woman how old she is
and how much she weight uh normally yes
but in some occasions i just asked them
to guess i think like as long as the man
answers the same question equality here
uh yes a little bit yeah
but i mean generally a little bit
yeah
yes only because of the patriarchal
[ __ ] that's
connected to it do you think it's
equally rude to ask a man how much money
he makes
you guys create the system so no
sorry no why do women stress about these
issues and what does it say about their
self-worth self-confidence i think it
has to do with like self-love
yeah exactly and like the society's
opinion reflects a lot on this would you
say when we when a dad abandons his
child he's a deadbeat dad oh you are
abandoning your child of course yeah
of course
yeah yes yeah yeah yeah so
what do you agree
what a question
he is a deadbeat dad so why is it when a
woman abandons her child we call it the
right to choose
no abortion i think is something that
you choose because no at the end of the
day you are the one that are looking
after that child and if you don't want
it why should anyone force you to have
something that maybe you cannot actually
give the life that a person should
deserve but you cannot give it
what it i disagree with the first
question i think it's subjective oh you
think it's subjective the first one yeah
i think you're mischaracterizing the
right to choose i don't think the right
to choose is abandoning i don't think
having an abortion is abandoning a child
at all i agree with that i don't call it
anything of the such in your deadbeat
mum what are you talking about okay okay
fair enough fair enough you think it's
equal though choose what fam
no no if she has an abortion we call it
the right to change oh
so she's she's abandoning her
the child's not born yet but it's still
a child right oh yeah sticky ones still
i
no but you know it is sometimes in life
if you're not in the right position you
got yet me you gotta do what's right for
the child you can't be bringing children
into struggle that's how you start
chefing each other on the block and and
selling star dog and selling freaking
everything in these things
but could it couldn't you say it's on
the woman to pick better men to have
kids with and maybe ones that want to be
fathers no no it's underwomen to use
contraception
the quail we got the pill we got condoms
we've got all sorts of things so do the
right thing do you think that men sense
we have a if we don't want to be mothers
right we can have an abortion do you
think men if they don't want to be a
father they should be able to have a
financial abortion yeah why not yeah you
agree okay but financial abortion what
do you mean
they just be like if you don't want to
have a child it's the same like they
don't want to have a child man why do
you have to force them i i don't want to
force i don't want you to force me to
have a [ __ ] child why would you yeah
if you think that throughout your life
you're not going to be able to like
sustain what it involves that i have a
child then i don't think somebody should
like have the you know keep up doing
something that they don't think they're
going to be able to keep you know it's
choice of both but ultimately that
decision should come down to choosing to
use protection or choosing to to be safe
doing it you can take we can take
preventative measures to avoid doing
that it shouldn't like it
couldn't you say women could take
preventative measures to do the same
thing absolutely absolutely but that
includes abortion if that be the case
well i'm not saying that she shouldn't
have an abortion i'm saying shouldn't a
man be able to have a financial abortion
where he's not on the hook for child
support because we're trying to be equal
right yeah is his child
is an agreement isn't it
a child support is like much based on
how much the parent owns
so like if the father doesn't own a lot
there's a cap about how much they have
to earn before they have to pay child
support so they have to earn above a
certain amount before they pay but
wouldn't that incentivize women to get
kids off of rich guys say drake but in
which case in which case the men should
potentially be more careful because we
can prevent them
it's easy
so
that's the problem is a man can do
everything right and a woman can still
steal a condom the nba gave out
statements telling men to flush condoms
and that's a guy that does everything
right right i agree that that's an issue
i agree that that's because because of
that don't you think that men should be
able to have a financial abortion
no no no no
no no
um it is
i mean
it takes two to tango so
so you know
yeah just use contraception you know i'm
saying everything will be easier no i
ain't gonna go through no pain and
suffering you feel me god
let me we're on this earth to live life
not suffer you feel me what happened to
drake what happened to drake used
contraception what happened to drake
what happened to him fam is it my boy
what are you not talking about
the hot sauce he wore a condom with a
model right and she stole it and tried
to put it up okay now she needs to go to
jail right all right
that's rape
because of things like that don't you
think there should be a financial
abortion because right now women are
incentivized to get a kid off of a rich
guy now do you know what you're saying
so many words that i don't understand so
it's like i've got a to get it do the
right thing you know what i'm saying if
you're not ready for a kid use condoms
if you yeah
all right y'all what's your name noah
adam ryan if a man abandons his child is
he a deadbeat dad depends on his
circumstances yes i'll agree with noah
why do we when a woman abandons her
child and gets an abortion we call it
the right to choose wait wait
like the right we call it her choice
yeah i agree with that though so i'm
saying if if a man abandons his child
he's a deadbeat dad right no i said it
depends on circumstances you're right
you're right but i'm saying in society
typically that's what they say yeah i
agree so why don't we call women
deadbeat moms when they get an abortion
because it's a different situation
so if we're going to talk about their
body right should someone be able to get
an abortion the day before they give
birth no no no why it's their body
because the kid is alive yeah i think i
think the kid is alive and to be fair to
be fair i disagree um i think in
situations for example that a woman gets
right for example she should have the
right to have an abortion at any time
that she decides because it isn't her
choice
and sometimes it takes a long time to
decide on what you want so if it takes
up until then then if you don't want
that child i think you can decide what
you want nine months old yeah i think
you should decide nine months i
personally disagree but yeah nine months
nine months is a little bit too far and
that muscles are definitely a little bit
too far but i think you should you
should make your decision before that
you should know what you want before
that so it shouldn't take nine months i
i disagree on a basis that there should
be a cutoff point and if you can't
decide before that point the child
deserves to be born but i like
circumstances of when women become
pregnant they should have a prolonged
period of time to speak like to
understand what they want and like
understand the circumstances of which to
become pregnant um but there has to be a
cutoff point because at some point the
kid becomes alive what do you think of
the cutoff point in the uk it's 24 weeks
i think that i think that's up for
discussion but for me personally i'm a
man i don't see any issue with that yeah
i think that's a lot yeah i do but from
from seeing women go through it you can
see that it does scar them even to that
later stage but i do think they deserve
the choice to be able to do it did you
know the earliest pregnancy to survive
is 21 weeks
so it's legal up to 24 weeks but the
earliest child to survive birth is 21
weeks i think that i think that's i
think
that stat
is designed to like
make you think certain things
so i don't agree with it
bro what are you talking about man you
don't agree with the stat no i don't i
agree with it but i don't agree with it
because how many how many children have
been born at 21 weeks
i don't think you could use exaggerated
statistics to be able to
it's not an exaggerated step to say the
earliest to say that earliest pregnancy
was at 21 weeks then no i know it is but
to use that to basically determine what
the average should be is not a fair
statistic how many kids have been born
at 21 weeks oh it's rare so so therefore
24 weeks is a good mean average for kids
to be cut off and
after a certain point to have a kid
removed from a a female means that the
female can never have kids again so
you've got to put it before they're cut
off before a female can never have a kid
again because once she's been raped and
then she can't have a kid again because
of that man that's very bad however one
point that i do always think about i'm
kind of 50 50 with the subject i do
think that before you have sex you know
the complications if you have
unprotected sex you know what the
complications are and you know what's
going to happen for example if you get
an sti or a sexually transmitted disease
you know the complications you decided
to use um like you decided to have
unprotected sex so you know the
consequences but however some people do
want to take the risk and some people do
want to enjoy certain things so i think
you shouldn't be judged on what you do
and you should have a choice i do
believe do you think it's okay to use
abortion as a form of birth control no
because it diminishes uh
government uh
government money it diminishes like the
thought process behind it if you think
oh i can i can have sex unprotected but
someone else will deal with it for me
that presents a problem so you need to
be able to accept the consequences for
having unprotected sex and if you want
to resort to plan b i think that's a
viable option and a lot of people have
done it i myself can say that i've had
to resort to plan b once before twice
before but resorting to abortion is like
i can't agree with that ever so you
think it should be like it's like a last
resort yeah i think i think it depends
on your situation if you're having like
unprotected sex constantly and using
abortions constantly then that's
different that's a different situation
but if it's a one-off and a one-off
moment that you decide to have
unprotected and you don't want the child
or for example a situation where you've
been sexually assaulted or raised or for
example and there's that one
particular situation where you need an
abortion then i think you should have it
but it shouldn't be a constant thing did
you know that 40 of women that get
abortions have had two or more already
and it doesn't track the 60 to see if
they get one in the future is that u.s
or uk u.s that's u.s that's a bit of a
difficult situation because it just it
just seems like it's it's being used as
a form of birth control with those
numbers i think
i just want to say um with a form of
government regulation like what happened
in in the us
i don't think i think people should be
given the choice but i don't think it's
government's right to involve themselves
in the morality of that situation
through legislation i think there could
be other forms of regulation for example
fines or other things like that but i
don't think a complete ban should be um
should be allowed in that situation i
think it's a very sensitive situation
it's very 50 50 and to involve something
to be a complete ban
i think it's an infringement on a lot of
people's rights
and i think it could be other measures
to be taken in for the for the us the
supreme court in us yeah has decided
that it's up to each individual state
and their law um like so
for the us attorney of each individual
state can decide the regulations on uh
abortion which means for example in
places like texas where it's very white
male orientated they will decide
how many states agreed with the the
complete ban well there have no states
have completely banned abortion at this
point there probably will be some that
do but typically you can just drive to
another state and a lot of people make
it an income issue but only eight
percent of women over under the poverty
line are getting abortions where one in
three women that make over forty seven
thousand dollars per year are getting
abortions so typically those women have
the money to do it yeah so i would say a
good law to impl uh put in place would
be if you've had for example one or more
then there should be a very very big
payout that you should have to pay if
you desperately do need it um maybe that
would regulate it a little bit more than
people just taking like five or more
abortions just for free constantly then
i think that would be a better way to
solve it it's not free like it is here
like here it's free up to six months you
have to pay for it but it doesn't really
seem to be stopping anything but then
then i would say that whatever the pay
is if you have it more if you've had it
more than once or twice i'd say twice
because you should have learned your
lesson from you would think right you
think you should learn your lesson so
maybe after twice you should charge a
lot more than
i would add if
two times free of charge third time it
triples the value you paid for the first
one i i think that like the topic of
conversation should be more about the
um the legislation than the actual
morality of it um because it's a very
divided subject the problem isn't
whether it's right or wrong because some
people think it's okay some people don't
think it's okay but and then the issue
comes with with government's
infringement on people's decision-making
and america is a very liberal country
the idea is that everyone has their own
right so i think when you've created and
first of all democracy is a bit um it's
a bit skewed in a sense it's not exactly
free and and it's not no one not
everyone has a fair choice
and a fair vote so i think like if the
legislation is more of the problem and
not the usher morale do you think the
question should be more when does life
begin because we can't i think we can
agree that like for the most part i know
i know forgot one of you said the
exception with grape sorry say great
youtube yeah but for the most part like
a woman shouldn't kill her kid the day
before she gives birth right like we
would agree that's that's wrong so it's
not about morality it's about more like
when does the kid a kid right because
because i think we all want to protect
children right
so i would say using an example of one
day before birth is quite an extreme
example you shouldn't have to go to the
extremes to prove the point right right
for sure but you should have made your
decision way before i agree one day
before your birth if you've decided to
have unprotected sex the point
what are you doing at six months like
where have you been sure exactly if it
takes six months for you to decide what
you want and i don't think you're
capable of even being a mother i think
if you're ready to have a child then you
should know you're ready to have a child
i don't think you should take the day
before you give birth to decide you know
what i want this or maybe i don't i
think you should have decided when you
had unprotected sex or even a couple
weeks after you had unprotected sex when
you found that you were pregnant don't
you think this takes responsibility off
of women though because isn't it in our
control who we sleep with and let's not
talk about grape right that's not that's
not what i'm talking about yeah yeah but
but in that case like we're in control
of who we sleep with so shouldn't we
just make better decisions about who we
sleep with no because
that's give out the [ __ ]
no no no no no yes no i look i agree i
agree with that statement but i also
don't agree with that what i'm saying is
women have the right to choose you to
sleep with
that's not like
that's not alone like that's not up for
debate women can sleep with her they
want to sleep with
the way you sleep with someone is
completely up to you
you can say like no you can you can
sleep with whoever but i'm talking about
then you don't have to deal with the
consequence right we're taking no no but
i'm saying women don't have to deal with
the consequence because we're always
bailed out
do you think like
i think a lot of it is you're assuming
uh humans have complete rationality a
lot of the time they make these errors
and they make these mistakes but they
have to have the the ultimatum to be
able to like deal with the consequences
of their decisions but like abortion
gives them that opportunity it gives
them that choice to be able to do it
granted there's there's not deal with
the consequences of their actions right
yeah but yeah no no but because i'm a
woman right and i could i could have
self-control right there's no but i
think there's no you can and i think but
i think people can but humans are not
naturally
they're not completely rational we do
make mistakes and we can't assume that
everyone has clear decision making and
clear consciousness i mean you look at
some grown adult no okay i'll give it
i'll give an example i'll give it i'll
give you something because i will say
the abortion numbers are going up
outside like the age the average first
stage of abortion is going up for
example a lot of people here are out
right now they're a bit drunk they're a
bit tipsy how many times have you i've
done a few drink but i don't drink oh
okay well i know i can speak for people
who do drink
a lot if you if you don't drink you're
missing on a whole opportunity of like
conversation
i'll explain it yeah a serious situation
people for example have gone out they've
had nights out they've met someone in
the club in on the influence of alcohol
and alcohol there's a lot of people
alcohol influences a lot of decisions
and a lot of people that are drunk and
under the influence of alcohol are not
going to make the decision of but this
keeps coming back to accountability
we're giving them excuses
like yeah but like i said before like
there's many mistakes that people can
make that they regret but you have to
give them the opportunity to be able to
correct those mistakes because people
make those mistakes i mean like i said
you can give it you can give an example
with um
like i don't know if you've ever heard
of cambridge analytica they were a data
analysis company that used psychological
intervention to be able to manipulate
minds in terms of the voting process so
you can clearly see that the people that
will actually vote
you can clearly see that the people
actually voting were being influenced by
certain decisions based on what was
shown on social media and things like
that so people aren't completely
rational so if you assume complete
people are completely rational the
abortion debate becomes a bit different
because you start to think okay do you
think women are incapable of making
decisions no i'm seeing a lot of humor a
lot of humans have certain um biases and
tendencies to not make the right
rational decision
you you've probably experienced it in
your life as well we've experienced it
in our lives as well everyone has
experienced it and it's not to do with
women i'm not playing any playing into
any identities or grouping anyone but
the natural tendency for humans are not
perfect we're not computers
when you take away the consequence of
something like more people do it and
i've talked i've talked to women that
have had abortions right they'll call
and i do a show and they and i ask them
this question every time would you have
been more careful if there weren't if
abortion wasn't a fail safe and they
also said yes
and so it's like
where is the line where women are
weren't used using it because i'm not
even saying ban it completely but i'm
saying where is the line where women
where women are used just using it as a
form of birth control so i think there
should be a regulation i understand like
like ryan said there is people that do
make mistakes and every human does make
mistakes and there'll be times where
whatever the situation is it could be
alcohol it could be whatever whatever
the situation is where you do have
unprotected sex and you do know the risk
but you still take the the situation and
it does happen and i think women should
be entitled to have an abortion if but
there is a certain amount so for example
if a woman is taking abortions after
abortion and using it as birth and
control then there should be
some right so for example maybe one or
two two or more
abortions then you should have to pay
like double the amount triple the amount
could you put the amount i don't think
it's the question of morality because
it's a bit skewed a lot of people debate
it there's many there's many people that
are on each side i think the question is
legislation how can you deal with that
situation when people are of different
values like you can't completely ban it
because then that that's what that music
yeah same value but but maybe like
financial sanctions or the question is
how can we regulate it's not whether
it's right or wrong because i don't
think people are going to agree with
that you're not going to get everyone to
one side i think the legislation is the
most important thing to be able to do
yeah well thank you guys for stopping i
appreciate it okay so this is where
things got sticky so i talked to these
guys for like 15 minutes right
and i give them you guys just saw the
interview i give them all this time and
attention i feel like i'm just talking
in circles with them and it didn't
really seem like a good use of my time
so i say next next person right no so so
what i was saying is i just don't think
it should be legal like i think you're
capable of making your own decisions as
a grown ass woman
the men after proceeded to ask me if i
was pro-life which i said yes
and
they kept
talking and wanting to argue with me and
what i should have done which should
have just said hey i need to go on to
the next people
but um
because i was arguing with them off
camera i'm like you know i don't do this
[ __ ] for free i don't argue for free so
i turn on the camera again do you think
like completely yeah that's what so i
think
yeah i've i've been it's been i've never
gotten pregnant and it's been really
easy it's been really easy but do you
know what do you not have enough empathy
to understand other people's situations
like okay i know a couple girls that
have i know a couple girls that have
gotten abortions okay and all of them
are irresponsible yeah so so
i mean you've studied economics you're
you could say the upper
echelons of intellect yeah and
consciousness and understanding over
certain situations but most of most part
of the population are not
so can you not see i haven't like see
those people
may not have enough understanding to
understand the consequences of their
situations i mean you look at economic
for example you studied economics
there's a lot of
areas in behavioral economics where you
can see people's irrationality their
incapability to understand decisions so
are you telling me grown adults don't
know what's going to happen if they have
sex
no i'm not i'm not saying that but i'm
saying they actually don't know because
i i don't know what's going to happen
when i have sex there's a lot of people
that are subject to emotional
manipulation for example so when they
get into a relationship they don't you
don't act rationally so if it's a lot of
people in relationships
they look back after the relationship
and they look back and they say wow what
was i doing i wasn't thinking straight
yeah is that not a clear way of showing
the irrationality i think grown adults
are capable if you're capable of making
the decision to have sex you should deal
with the consequence okay you you made
that choice right i'm not gonna coddle
women and act like like we're not
capable of making sure i think women are
smart i think i think we're more
empowered than we've ever been and i
think women can make choices
yeah and i think they know
like and we have we have we have plan b
we have an iud we have birth control
well you call it the coil here right we
have adoption okay we have
abstinence that's five five protection
and if you if you were dumb enough to
not do all five of those things that's
on you
that's on you nothing to just completely
call it dumb is is like it is but it's
not as one of those people she was an
idiot if it's not it's not i don't get
any more i don't think it's being it's
been it's being smart about the the
decision i think and that's what a lot
of i think smart i know i think smart to
have a unplanned pregnancy i think a lot
of conservatives um what what they tend
to do
um for example ben shapiro or milo
yiannopoulos like they tend to assume
that everyone is completely irrational
and i don't think that's that's are you
assuming everyone's irrational no you
think women are dumb i'm assuming that
people are complete are not completely
rational they don't make the decisions
that they should be women are irrational
no i'm i'm not saying i'm saying women
like we can make our own decisions women
i'm saying this is about women this is
who we're talking about we're talking
about women okay well i'm saying humans
inherently i'm talking about women okay
well do women fall under the human
category yeah
so so they are irrational
but as well as men men make bad
decisions as well but just because you
make bad decisions you should deal with
the consequence if i if i speed and i
and i get a ticket that's the
consequence the consequences are fine
yes yeah but it could be it could be
is it it could yeah yeah
it could be it could be if i hit someone
if i'm speeding i hit someone it could
be okay but the idea with the
legislation are you kind of parenting a
life sentence it's different
you have to section the two different
different areas yeah
my my argument is humans are inherently
irrational yeah to an extent not
completely to an extent you can't assume
that every every human is rational
because they are not and if you if
you're if you're doing a degree you are
in the upper echelon of intellect right
if you want but how most of the
population are not in that you realize
most abortions are from people that make
women that make forty seven thousand
dollars or more a year okay so it's 40
so so this is the upper ex actually and
women with college degrees get more
abortions
so this is the upper upper intellect
yeah yeah but just because that argument
doesn't make sense just because you're
an operational doesn't mean that you can
be you're you're irrational it doesn't
no i'm saying i mean the argument that
i'm in the upper excellent or whatever
that big word
of intelligence right because i got a
degree right but that doesn't mean that
you you're not subject to irrationality
a lot of people make that same mistake
you look at financial markets most
people that operate in financial markets
have degrees most people are very smart
yeah but they still have a lot of
irrationality when it comes to and they
have to deal with the consequence when
the market falls yeah but why do why
don't why do i need to be bailed out
your argument with abortion is that it
should be made completely illegal
i'm not saying that i'm saying the
legislation the legislation should allow
financial sanctions that is the problem
is with the legislation it's not with
the the morality of the situation to
make it completely illegal wouldn't be
right you said with the markets when
they act irrational they face financial
sanctions right no i said they they get
counsel like if you invest in the wrong
stock
you lose money you lose money okay so if
i if i invest in the wrong dude
and i don't use protection the five
forms of birth control there are like
that's that's on me so why why wouldn't
you want to issue financial sanctions
instead of just completely making it
illegal instead of completely making it
illegal like why wouldn't you want to
issue financial science
why because i'm saying why why do we
have to get involved the government i
don't think the government should get
involved i think like like that's what
i'm saying i'm saying like
we have to go so far to do financial
sanctions but you're saying you should
completely restrict someone of choice
yes in the us
yes instead of financial sanctions
you think financial sanctions is a
better idea for your second and third
abortion
uh yeah
i do i do because i think women just
making better decisions but you see i
think to be able to say that is a very
like it's a very simplistic version of
how you how you would assume a human is
you you you know yourself
okay so do you think humans active
rationalism what do you think they are
completely rational do i think women do
i think humans act rationally do you
think women act irrational i think
humans like to rationally yes to an
extent you act rationally of course
you're the you're the upper excellent of
rational so when okay so when when shops
when shops put on the prices 3.99 why do
they do that because people have
psychological biases to assume the price
is lower when it's 3.99
you don't do it because so that's
clearly an understanding of
irrationality but but here's the thing
here's the thing if women i've i've
asked women this question would you be
more careful if abortion wasn't a
fail-safe why do they keep telling me
yes because when there's a consequence
you do it less it's like it's it's yeah
if there's a consequence i've asked
women women this all the time so why
wouldn't we get rid of the consequence
so women must stop making poor decisions
no but my my idea is that humans are
inherently irrational that's the thing
i'm arguing i don't wanna i don't wanna
answer that question because i need to
think about that i'm not but again like
we're just talking in circles so i i'm
just like okay
you guys need to move on right so i end
up trying to do an another interview i'm
gonna think about on the sport okay well
i i need to go to the next person to see
up the video
so then these guys are going behind the
camera and every person i try to
interview they begin to tell them that
i'm pro-life even though this interview
wasn't even supposed to be about being
pro-life it was supposed to be about
father's rights that's what we're
sticking to and talking about because
pro-life is a completely different
conversation so then there's a group of
people gathering behind the camera uh
it's not a huge group but a small group
of people gathering behind the camera
basically talking [ __ ] because these
guys need to tell everybody that walks
by what i'm doing instead of just i
don't know minding your own business
so i'm trying to interview this next
girl and she says she's a youtuber she's
got 250k subs apparently i've never
heard of her but yeah i don't know
um so
this guy keeps getting closer and closer
to my camera and again i'm there by
myself i just have a tripod so i'm
nervous someone's gonna take it or do
something to it okay okay can i hold the
mic
you know she's not really helping the
situation because she's like egging it
on
um
and i'm just trying to interview people
so
and there's a whole group of people
behind the camera like
talking [ __ ] and all this stuff and you
can see when she walks in she comes in
with this like angry attitude because
the guys have just been talking to her
and
i really when i foster conversations i
really like it to be
at a point where we can have a
discussion and when you're not coming at
me with this energy so do you think that
if a man abandons his child he's a
deadbeat dad absolutely so do you think
why do we call why don't we call it a
woman who abandons her child the
deadbeat mom i'm assuming you're
pro-life
i'm talking about if she gets an
abortion if she gets an abortion is she
what abandoning her child
is she abandoned
i actually was really nervous during
this clip because this group of people
was forming behind the
camera there was a couple people getting
too close to my camera that i just had
to shut down the interview and go home
because i wasn't sure if it was a safe
situation anymore and i just wanted to
be safe so um i bounced but that was the
interview for the night and that's
everything i did so
yeah like the video please